you know but to me the the biggest
example that is Nerva camed offs
wrestling khabib takes oh my god
everybody everybody who's good ha failed
us on just Brazilian jiu-jitsu blackbelt
world champion rag dolls rag dolls
everybody Michael Johnson I wonder who
he fights he ragdoll this guy in the
beginning and I thought it was over
right away I was like oh this is over
and that but Iook into did did really
well did very well very well the thing
about Iaquinta is he's a legit crazy
person like that guy's crazy trash his
hotel rooms he's like you look at his
eyes like oh this is the guy like a
couple people home it's not a full
village in that head that's not a good
example but what I'm saying is like he's
a legit maniac and he's not scared like
he'll fight anybody yeah like you could
wake him up at 3 o'clock in the morning
and he'll fight anybody maybe crazy
thing he was screaming he was running
around the hotel lobby the day when when
we found out that max Holloway could not
make weight and then by the way I
shouldn't say could not make weight I
believe max would have made the way they
didn't State Athletic Commission which
they made some they made some big errors
and I can go into detail with a couple
of them one of them is they wouldn't let
Paul Felder fight Paul Felder wanted to
fight they said he's not ranked Paul
Felder is a [ __ ] killer he is a
straight-up killer and him versus kabhi
would have been a very interesting fight
because Paul is a big 155 he's very big
and very strong annie is an expert
world-class striker I mean Paul Felder
is a dangerous dangerous man for anybody
155 pounds and he's a grounded pound
expert
he's also got very good defense in in
everything very good defense standing up
very good defense on the ground we felt
was [ __ ] well-rounded I would been
very intrigued in that fight and they
offered it to Felder Felder said [ __ ]
yeah and then in Nevada start excuse me
New York State Athletic Commission said
and said now yeah I was like you guys
are out of your [ __ ] minds you don't
know [ __ ] about fighting if you don't
think that guy could fight for the title
because Paul might be fighting for the
title and a year from now or whatever I
mean he's [ __ ] world-class so the
fact they don't know that and they're
saying well based on the rankings well
the rankings are horseshit they're
arbitrary
they're made by a bunch of people that I
think
times are biased they have terrible
judgment sometimes a guy will [ __ ] a guy
up and then you look at the rankings and
he's below that guy he just [ __ ] up in
the rantings explain that there was no
other way to tell if the guys better
than who he [ __ ] up and they say well
his past experience
suck fat dick that past experience
doesn't mean anything this guy beat this
guy you gotta beat the guy who beat the
guy that guy beat him well if he was
number one now he's number one that's
how it goes you can't get knocked out
and still be number one that's [ __ ]
bananas and this is often the case where
you see a guy beat a guy and he's still
below the guy in the rank he's like what
the [ __ ] else can he do how did I end up
with the guy how did they end up getting
Iaquinta them.this asked him he was in
he was the next guy in line he's on a
four or five fight win streak and he's
beating some very good guys like Jorge
Masvidal Ross Pearson he's beating some
legit guys and look I went that can bang
and he's tough as [ __ ] and he's got a
wrestling background which I think
played a big factor in that fight
obviously he was greatly outclassed by a
guy who I think is one of the greatest
lightweights of all time and now that
he's the champion I'm very interested in
seeing but I think what what we saw in
that fight that was very intriguing was
the fact that Iaquinta was able to get
back up and that I Quint was one of the
few guys that member gomad off has ever
fought that has stuffed a bunch of
takedowns and then into the late rounds
and this is a guy in Al that didn't even
prepare for a five-round fight yeah he
was getting ready for a three-round
fight with Paul Felder so I mean [ __ ]
props to al Iaquinta I mean [ __ ] out
of that great job as awesome animal and
major props to could that Kyle bopped me
a kid that fought sup beat that kid
savage cuz he ate everything he was
smiling he got punched in the face
smiling and coming on at the end of the
fight the end of three rounds of a
clinic I mean he's a beat put on a
clinic he did everything jump spinning
back kicks roundhouse kicks which kicks
he hit him with a switch kick there was
like Jesus bak nak took a couple to the
neck lock and still kept helmet still
kept coming blood coming out of his nose
his mouth we may so sticking his tongue
out of it and then as a beat is like
what the [ __ ] do I got to do to this guy
at the end of it bak knee ax got
pinned up against the cage and he's
throwing bombs I was crazy the whole
place the entire Barclay center on there
don't know [ __ ] I started screaming and
clapping it was phenomenal phenomenal
that's what I love you know and that was
in my mind that was worth the price of
admission for the whole paper of your
card just it was the best fight for sure
yeah for sure but to see I'll do that
just shows you that you know al is a
legit world-class fighter I mean
definitely is not on a level of Kobe but
nobody thought he was coming in I think
it was a in a lot of ways an upset just
the fact that he was able to go to the
distance and you see what khabib did to
so many other fighters me he mauled
everybody else and he bawled out for a
lot of the fight I mean look the guy's
the best wrestler at 155 ever I mean
ever he does things to world-class guys
that makes you just confused